تحمل الحرب في اوكرانيا اثارا صعبه على
اقتصادات الدول الناشئه ولعل الاقتصاد
المصري دليل على ذلك بعد ان محت الحرب 6
سنوات من مكاسب الاقتصاد المصري منذ بدء
تنفيذ برنامج الاصلاح الاقتصادي بالتعاون
مع صندوق النقد الدولي عام 2016
فقد تراجع احتياطي النقد الاجنبي ليسجل
ادنى مستوى له في اغسطس عند 33 مليارا
ومائه واربعين مليون دولار من 41 مليار
دولار في فبراير وتم خفض الجنيه ثلاث مرات
ورفع الفائده 800 نقطه اساس وسجل معدل
التضخم الاساسي نهايه يناير الماضي
31.2% على اساس سنوي كما خرجت استثمارات
للاجانب في ادوات الدين بقيمه 22 مليار
دولار هذه الاثار ولو بحده اقل تكررت بين
عدد من الدول الناشئه وسط التاثيرات
المستمره للحرب على الاقتصاد العالمي
عموما ولكن ربما هذه الاثار قد تفاقمت في
مصر نتيجه علاقتها الاقتصاديه بكل من
روسيا واوكرانيا عندنا تاثر نتيجه لعلاقه
مباشره قللت الدخل من السياحه
تاثر لارتفاع سعر القمح والمواد الغذائيه
اللي بتيجي من روسيا واوكرانيا
وتاثر غير مباشر نتيجه لسحب الاستثمارات
الساخنه اللي تم سحبها من السوق المصري
وده بالتالي دخلنا في دائره مفرده ان مصر
ابتدت لازم يكون لها رد فعل ورد فعلها
انها هتبتدي انها ترفع الفايده وده برضو
اثر على مصر انها زودت التكلفه على
المصنعين والتجار والمزارعين في مصر لما
رفعت الفائده زاد التضخم فالتضخم في مصر
زاد عندنا مشكله تانيه برضو ظهرت في الوقت
ده نتيجه لسحب الاستثمارات الساخنه وهي
نقص الدولار وللخروج من الازمه لجات مصر
الى صندوق النقد الدولي في اتفاقا جديدا
تحصل بموجبه على قرض بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات
دولار
طبعا الاقتصاد المصري بيمر بسنتين اعتقد
سنتين عشرين 23 وعشرين اربعه وعشرين هما
الاشد وطئه على الاقتصاد المصري مثير مثل
كل دول العالم لكن اقصاد المصري يعتقد
انهم سنتين محوريتين له الاقتصاد المصري
بشان كبير اذا تعافت الدوله المصريه
واستطاعت الدوله المصريه الالتزام بسداد
مديونياتها بشكل كبير والتفكير في كيفيه
الحصول على النقد الاجنبي لتوفير العجز
والعجز في ما بين المطلوب من الدوله
المصريه دفعه وما بين وايرادات الدوله
المصريه اعتقد ان هو ده العنصر العنصر
الهام دفع الدوله المصريه وقدرتها على
الالتزام بسداد مديونياتها خلال السنتين
القادمين 20 23
اذا مرت هذه الفتره على الدوله المصريه
بخير اعتقد ان التعافي سيكون بدايه من 20
25 وهي مرحله هامه جدا ويجب ان يكون
للدوله المصريه خطه طموحه جدا في رؤيه
عامه لاستراتيجيه وطنيه للاقتصاد فيما بعد
هذه المرحله
معاناه الاقتصاد المصري ليس من المتوقع ان
تنتهي قريبا خاصه مع استمرار الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتبعتها على الاقتصاد
العالمي والتي تتزامن مع سياسه نقديه
تشدديه رفعت اسعار الفائده عالميا
لمستويات قياسيه ما يصعب من قدره الدول
الناشئه على الحصول على التمويل او خدمته
محمد زهير العربيه